[Music]
well let's take you now to a live event
Happening Here in the Kat Capital Doha
the Turkish foreign minister hakan fidan
will shortly speak alongside as you can
see qatar's prime minister and foreign
minister Sheik Muhammad bin Abdul Rahman
althani let's listen inity and we call
for all the parties to uh avoid plunging
the entire region into mayam which will
give rise to unbearable crisis we
totally reject the DU will standard in
embracing this crisis any human life is
precious we cannot condemn killing on
one side and Justified on the other all
the parties involved in the violation of
the international law must be held
accountable or we will be living in the
jungle our discussion today with his
Excellency the foreign Ministry of
turkey We examined all the dimensions
political and diplomatic we also sought
mechanism and tools to avoid further
excalion and to reach a ceasefire on all
fronts and also to avoid all forms of
targeting civilians namely women and
children we commend the stand taken by
the brotherly state of turkey in support
of the rights of the Palestinian people
and we agree with them in all the STS as
we have converging views during the
joint meetings we had also a joint and
shared
stand in this respect the state ofq
condemned the collective punishment
policy inflicted on Gaza and the Gaza
and as we speak more than 2.3 million
Palestinians are denied their basic
necessities food water electricity and
medical supplies this is a flagrant
violation of international
law unfortunately we find the Dual
standard prevailing in the International
Community in this particular respect as
the
humanitarian Aid is politicized and even
used as a weapon for further P
punishment and we cannot find anyone
moving a finger to alleviate the
suffering of people in Gaza Strip uh
during the meeting
also we
reiterated that the delivery of
humanitarian Aid all across Gaza is an
imperative
here I would like to point out that we
are surprised with the statements made
by some Israeli for officials darting
false accusations against Qatar while we
are doing all what we can to avoid
escalation and help release the captives
these provocative statements cannot be
interpreted by uh political political
propaganda and and political blackmail
the efforts exerted by the state of cter
and the must be hailed and commended we
are adamant the peaceful and solution to
this crisis and keeping all the channels
of communication open with all the
concerned parties uh we quick response
is a must in order to avoid further
exacerbation of the crisis and we
commend all the Regional International
efforts within this context we renew our
invite to our International Partners to
Rally efforts in order to reach a
lasting solution of the Palestinian
cause with the importance of
invigoration of the international
organizations including the United
Nations to address the humanitarian
issues and to continue to communicate
with all the concerned to have the
captives uh released as soon as possible
we also commend the effort exerted by
our regional Partners including turkey
and we reiterate that peace a lasting
peace for an permanent solution for the
Palestinian cause within the
international resolutions and the Arab
peace initiative will be a
must members of the
breast
your Excellency Muhammad ABD
Al
I extend all thanks and appreciation for
the warm reception
and during this
meeting uh I had the opportunity to meet
with his ex his Royal
Highness
bamed
we
renew our resolve to continue to
cooperate in this
front during our meeting
we discussed the future meeting of the
Supreme strategic Council which will be
convened in
Doha there is no doubt in addition to
the bilateral
relations
meeting addressed the issue of the
crisis in
Gaza the whole world is hurt by what is
taking place in Gaza Israel is tarting
civilians even in hospitals and places
of
worship every human being with a
conscience should act to put an end to
this
brutality we should act together and in
unity we are doing our best to ensure
this I paid a visit to
tahran also Beirut J and before that
Kyo with close coordination and
cooperation with the regional leaders we
are doing our best to end this crisis
the Turkish president also is uh has and
continues to initiate Communications
with world leaders with the aim
of ending this
war as you are aware what Israel the
Israeli occupation forces are exercising
is a collective punishment against all
the residents of
Gaza the gazans cannot be approached
from their homes from their
Homeland if the crisis spells
over there will be it will exaggerate to
reach Regional countries and no country
will be safe Israel must refrain from
further
escalation can be turned into a
holocaust
ceasefire immediate ceasefire is
imperative and safe Corridor for
humanitarian Aid is also a must we are
at a turning point in History either we
reach a lasting peace or a World War
will
break we call for all the parties and
Regional International stakeholders to
listen to the voice of
reason and those who are encouraging
Israel to continue their
crimes are also
liable if we do not act fast we will
have darker days to
come we are certain that
nothing could be achieved without mere
criticism or condemnation as Israel has
been
violating International laws for years
and therefore
tangible measures are required is it
possible to achieve lasting peace
without a fair diplomatic and political
solution to the Palestinian
cause Israel
must realize that they
cannot have peace and security with
violence today victories may lead to
Future defeats the only solution is to
have the independent Palestinian state
established on the basis of
1967 borders with East Jerusalem at its
capital all the parties must live up to
their respective responsibilities and
initiate and take these practical
measures that's
why
for foreign
speech for speech for speech
for constructive role within with
respect to the humanitarian situation in
Gaza they
also uh
demonstrated finess in their mediation
which are highly commended we will
continue to coordinate with the state of
qter this meeting of today was very
significant in this respect therefore we
call on the International Community to
support genuinely support all the
initiative aiming for peace once again
thank you
your Excellency for the warm reception
and general uh generous
hospitality